[Music]
we all know anything can happen out
there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we
suffer we keep going that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meatball look
somebody likes my meatballs hey Paw
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win 3 2 1 there's a
young boy living in the city all they do
was over the next 10 days these athletes
will cross 400 miles climbing biking and
kaying that dot is Daddy go daddy
by let's talk again to meatball 3 days
to 200 miles ago leave the stupid dog
and let's go come on move dumb dog what
is it boy oh oh God can't believe I
almost walked right off that Cliff than
meat balls for you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were on bikes and zip lines and
running and climbing he must have wings
we don't know about boy you know I'm
back like I never left you want to try
to embase the buckets of pain I need a
bigger bucket team broad rail has
traveled over 200 miles and they' found
a companion Daddy has a dog what have
you done think you found your new
partner in suffering Michael yeah he's
the king I think we should call him
Arthur Arthur the
king how's he doing he's been through so
much this bu needs a vit I don't want
you to hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like you GL famous dog
looks even worse than the rest of you
maybe you all deserve each other always
underestimated nor my
Budd this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
[Music]
King I've never seen anything like this
everybody knows about
[Music]
it guess what I'm not a dog
person
[Music]